obviously I'm a comedian I'm not a rap
star but I want to be as bad as one and
I want people to know that hey there
this is how to trash your hotel room
okay MacKinnon first thing that's gotta
go is the chandelier yeah I dropped that
sucker there are a lot of different
methodologies for how to accomplish this
I've developed my own method over years
and years of doing it that's a pool of
ash you could say it's a little sadistic
but I just I have to be creative I get
in the hotel room and I think how can I
make this the worst possible situation
these people have ever seen I want them
to walk in and be wowed quick little
thing that really causes a lot of damage
and a short amount of time take the
electrical cord out mangle it with your
chief and then plug it back in and it's
gonna take those people a while to
figure out why the phone's not working
if there's any satine finishes
immediately shred those I keep a long
nail and people think it's a coconut
it's just for shredding satine you can
take the stuff in the minibar dump it
out throw food you know we've seen it
we've read about it there has to be a
music to it a cigarette is your
paintbrush you can draw a horse or a
dick it's small things it's creating
work where there ought to be work any
food that you don't eat put it in a
drawer smear it on the Bible and close
it it's gonna take them a long time to
figure out where the smells coming from
you know the curtains can't stay mirror
hole just hurl it like a discus if any
big pieces fall take that big piece
smash it over your knee in a different
part of the room really
scatter the ashes it's the hardest to
clean up and the most dangerous for
people's fingers to deal with all those
shreds of glass Travel is one of the
great joys of life and that's because
every hotel room is different
have you ever trashed a yurt a yurt yep
yeah just here
you